et c'est moment de recevoir l'invité de
paris 10 oct
bonjour rémy riou bonjour merci de venir
jusqu'à nous directeur de l'agencé
française de développement l'afd vous co
publié avec achille mbembe et séverine
kodjo grandvaux ce livre qui s'intitule
pour un mondant comme un regard croisé
entre l'afrique et l'europe on va entrer
dans le fond dans un instant mais avant
cela si vous le voulez bien on s'arrête
sur cette actualité de la guerre en
ukraine un chiffre et une image aussi
l'assemblée générale de l'onu adoptée en
mars dernier une résolution condamnant
l'intervention russe 140 votes pour 5
votre contre 30 8 abstentions la majeure
partie de ces abstentions sont
africaines sept pays toujours africains
n'ont pas pris part au vote qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de cette façon des
pays africains de voter sur cette
affaire qui concerne le monde entier bon
là la guerre en ukraine on a vu cette
actualité si lourde elle nous concerne
tous nous mêmes à l'afd on a fait un
prêt de 300 millions d'euros à la
semaine dernière à l'ukraine pour
contribuer à la réponse est bien sûr
l'afrique 30% des exportations de blé
africaine viennent d'ukraine et de et de
russie 80% en egypte
donc il ya effectivement une très grande
inquiétude sur les conséquences de la
crise bon je crois que le vote est quand
même meilleur en 2022 qu'en 2014 au
moment de la crimée donc il ya quand
même l'union africaine qui a pris une
position assez claire au delà dessus de
chacun de ces pays et puis je crois
qu'il ya en afrique c'est un peu le
thème de notre livre il ya la crainte du
retour de la guerre froide il ya la
crainte d'un monde qui continue à se
fracturer et dont l'afrique finalement
paye comme autrefois un prix très lourd
du coup ce qu'il fallait y voir ou pas
d'ailleurs une certaine volonté de
certains pays africains de se tenir à
l'écart des affaires du monde tout au
moins celle du moment oui je crois qu'on
est dans un moment où l'afrique
sans qu'il ya moins forte domination il
ya un moment d'affirmation peut-être de
l'afrique dans le monde et la volonté de
nouer des liens renouvelé avec les
autres régions du monde en particulier
avec l'europe le livre donc pour un
mondant comme un regard croisé entre
l'afrique et l'europe avec achille
mbembe d'eau est partie le projet
qu'elle est un concept alors bon d'abord
c'est un grand honneur ça a été un grand
bonheur d'avoir ce dialogue avec achille
mbembe vous vous le connaissez vous
l'avez sans doute très souvent reçue
c'est un immense historiens politologues
de l'afrique de l'afrique monde
précisément de de l'afrique dans le
monde et donc vous savez h il a
participé au sommet de montpellier le
nouveau sommet sur l'afrique et la
france il avait déposé un rapport sur
comment renouveler nos liens et puis
pendant le sommet de montpellier l'avait
peut parler en fait donc on s'est dit
que c'était bien de et moi et moi même
je n'avais pas parlé donc on s'est dit
que c'était bien peut-être de reprendre
cette balle et puis de l'approfondir
peut-être sur un format plus long
dans cette perspective vraiment d'un
renouvellement est justement semaines
montpellier vous dites vous rémy riou
qu'après cette rencontre de montpellier
après aussi celles de ouagadougou il
s'est ouvert un nouvel espace de
redéfinition je vous cite des relations
avec le continent africain et que cet
espace il faut l'occuper - pas de la
repentance ou du pardon que part de la
vérité de l'action la repentance c'est
un mot politiquement chargé surtout dans
le contexte actuel quel sens où va-t-il
pour l'historien que vous êtes
alors on sait la deuxième partie du
livre on a on a tout un chapitre sur
comment dépasser cet héritage colonial
moi j'aime pas beaucoup le mot de
repentance je pense qu'on a d'abord à
faire un travail de vérité c'est à dire
ce qu'on a fait finalement avec le
rwanda avec le rapport de la commission
de vincent duclert c'est à dire établir
les faits pour avoir une base claire et
solide et puis ajoutez un travail de
réconciliation c'est-à-dire un travail
eu d'action finalement un travail
d'investissement un travail pour ouvrir
un nouvel espace commun bien sûr si le
partenaire le souhaitent et à mon avis
c'est absolument urgent j'étais la
semaine dernière en afrique dans la
région des grands lacs bon quand vous
allez en ouganda vous constatez 80% de
la population a moins de 30 ans donc il
faut absolument parler trouver une façon
de créer du lien avec cette jeunesse
africaine la connecter à la nôtre une
espèce de triptyque mémoire vérité
action l'historien encore chez vous rémy
riou vous retrouver à la tête de l'afd
qui est allé pour aller vite une espèce
de grosse banque 4000 salariés 12
milliards d'euros annuels d'activité
c'est l'un des bras armé de la politique
française qu'est ce que carey la place
de l'histoire dans votre travail alors
c'est une très vieille maison c'est la
plus vieille institution internationale
de financement du développement l'afd à
l'aîné d'ailleurs au moment d'une autre
guerre en europe c'était en 1941 elle
est née à londres elle est née en
afrique en afrique centrale donc c'est
pour ça aussi que la crise ukrainienne
aujourd'hui les vagues qu'elle est en
train de créer dans le monde entier ça
résonne très très fort chez nous comme
résonne la force l'inventivité la
jeunesse de l'afrique est ce qu'on fait
à l'afd alors on a beaucoup avancé
depuis six ans on a créé effectivement
une institution je crois qu'il ya qui a
la taille critique qui est pertinente au
plan international maintenant il faut la
positionner dans son rôle exact c'est la
troisième partie du livre pour une
diplomatie du vivant c'est à dire une
institution qui est vraiment du côté des
autres qui gérait la capacité d'empathie
la capacité d'action la capacité de
réconciliation de la france à
l'international je vais vous demander
dans un instant qu'est ce que c'est que
cette diplomatie du violon je suis le
moins nouveau mais on si on parle des
relations entre l'afrique et l'europe on
ne peut pas ne pas reposer la question
du du positionnement de la france sur ce
qui à fric 1 par rapport à d'autres
acteurs qui sont de plus en plus
important on parle de la chine on parle
de la russie en par la turquie est ce
que vous comprenez rémy riou que la
france perde en influence ou
très mal vus par des populations
entières quelles réponses par exemple
vous donner à un jeune qui dit à la
france france dehors on vous a assez vu
alors je je comprends cette volonté de
sortir d'un d'un moule on l'appelait la
françafrique autrefois une forme
qu'après notre relation et qui de mon
point de vue est devenue vide en fête
est devenue et nous et nous gêne
finalement comme un costume un peu trop
étroits ou un peu trop serré et donc il
ya vraiment je crois que c'était l'objet
du sommet de montpellier la volonté de
briser ce moule de telle sorte que notre
relation prennent une autre forme une
forme plus vaste probablement une femme
plus vivante évidemment dans le plus
grand respect et l'esprit d'un
partenariat si nos partenaires africains
l'acceptent en tenant compte du fait que
la france est africaine on a 20 % de
notre population qui a une origine
africaine on a près d'un million de nos
concitoyens qui vivent à la réunion où
est la réunion si ce n'est en afrique
j'ai eu cette discussion avec le
président museveni
je suis livré à kampala j'ai vu le
président museveni il m'a dit ça il m'a
dit la france évidemment à cette très
longue histoire à cette présence en
afrique il faut le reconnaître il faut
en faire quelque chose et que
faudra-t-il justement faire dans
l'immédiat pour aulnoye et redéfinir ses
relations je crois qu'il faut investir
en fait c'est à dire il faut prêter
attention à ce qui se passe aux
solutions qui sont en train de naître
partout en afrique et il faut non pas
dans une logique dead je crois qu'il
faut arrêter de parler d' aide au
développement ça lasse tout le monde il
faut parler d'investissements il faut
parler d'investissement solidaire il
faut s'intéresser aux intérêts des
autres de telle sorte qu on les relit
avec ceux de la france et ceux de
l'europe parce qu on a eu cette très
grande crise climatique de nos modèles
économiques de la biodiversité cette
crise maintenant géopolitique
qui nous concerne tous et sur lequel il
faut inventer des solutions communes et
cette solution combine ça se casse cette
diplomatie du
vivant alors je oui mais alors moi ma
responsabilité c'est de diriger depuis
six ans l' agence française de
développement donc qui est effectivement
celle qui met en oeuvre la politique de
développement de la france et je cherche
depuis six ans finalement à définir à
quoi ça sert la politique de
développement d'un petit peu oublié
autrefois et il me semble que c'est
cette capacité de la france dans le
monde à créer du lien positif en fait
affaire avec et à se placer dans nous
ont dit à l'afp des 80 ans du côté des
autres c'est à dire vraiment une
capacité de décentrement j'irai même
dire de se placer de l'autre côté pour
en comprendre les logiques les forces
les nouveautés et puis regardez notre
pays avec un autre regard pour
contribuer à sa transformation donc on
est français bien sûr finalement pour
qu'on se comprenne bien à des projets
concrets matériel quantifiable alors
nous évidemment on a le droit de venir
sur votre plateau que parce que on fait
mille projets par an dont la moitié en
afrique j'étais encore une fois à la
centrale de production d'eau de khat
aussi la semaine dernière j'étais dans
les kivu les kivu c'est une zone
absolument fascinante j'étais à panzi
chez le docteur mukwege et qui répare
les femmes qui dit la force des femmes
j'étais voir les gorille de gros 1ers
cette région des grands lacs c'est une
région on a tendance à considérer que
l'afrique manque de quelque chose moi je
crois le contraire de ça quand on va
là-bas on voit c'est presque du trop
plein tout s'est empilé tout s'est
complexifié le développement c'est
probablement accompagnés des dynamiques
positives et encore une fois ce qui se
passe en afrique la façon dont ça va se
passer ça va nous inspirer dans notre
propre et dans les problèmes que nous
avons ici cela dit sans utopie ou une
utopie assumait
on est des gens très concret on a des
collègues qui sont toute la journée sur
le terrain auprès des populations
dans l'agriculture dans donc aucune
naïveté de notre côté soyez en certain
et sinon vous me rappelle leur y ait ce
matin encore une fois avec les titres de
votre journal mais oui un grand espoir
pas de fatalisme il se passe des
milliers de choses sur le terrain on est
un capteur new life d2 ces innovations
l'a voulu le partager avec vous merci
beaucoup le mérite d'être venu jusqu'à
nos co auteur avec achille mbembe et
séverine kodjo grandvaux de poing monde
en commun regards croisés entre
l'afrique et l'europe c' était l'invité
de ce vendredi merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci à vous